When we observe what we call fire,
we have a burning reaction,
and when we see these flames, what we actually see,
are the three types of heat transfer.
We observe conducting,
convection
and heat radiation simultaneously.
Let me write thermal radiation ...
I can also say "heat"
"thermal" convection and "thermal" radiation -
the word "thermal" simply refers to things that have to do with temperature.
What is conducting?
What we have here in the fuel for our fire,
for the fuel for our fire we have a classic burning reaction
and I encourage you to watch the video on this in the chemistry playlist
or the chemistry section if you are interested.
But you take carbon molecules and their bonds,
and then in the presence of oxygen and heat
you have a burning reaction,
which produces carbon dioxide and produces water
and even more energy than you put into the reaction,
so it produces a lot of energy.
And this energy will excite the molecules that are around it,
so you have these molecules,
which ultimately receive a lot of kinetic energy.
And remember that the temperature is proportional
of the average kinetic energy.
And those who were just burning,
or molecules just downstream of the reaction,
or perhaps those who were part of the reaction,
will have very high average kinetic energy,
because this burning reaction released all this energy.
And then they will hit other molecules,
who may not have such high kinetic energy,
but then they will transfer that kinetic energy
through these collisions.
And we have a whole video about the thermal performance,
but that's what's happening.
Things with high kinetic energy
are thrown into things with lower kinetic energy
and transfer some of that kinetic energy
and transfer part of this impulse.
This is definitely the case when we look at such a fire,
neighboring molecules are pushed into other molecules
and transfer energy.
Conviction - it revolves around the idea,
that the hot air is less dense.
If we have a lot of air particles here,
let's say this is the cool air here
and it is logical that the cool air will be denser than the warm air.
Because of the hot air, these particles have much higher kinetic energy
and they shall strike one another, and shall push one another
far farther and far away from each other,
due to this high average kinetic energy.
However, since the hot area is less dense,
this area here is less dense than the white area,
these may be the same molecule,
I just made them in different colors to show
less dense area and dense area,
it will rise upwards.
Or you can even think of it as a dense area ...
The dense area will fall around it
or will try to pass under it,
because it is thicker,
and the less dense area will climb up.
And having done this,
the hottest molecules will move up,
and the colder molecules can go down
to the heat source,
the energy source,
to be warmed up.
The hot air goes up -
let me record this - the hot air goes up.
When we think about it,
he makes room for the cold air to come down,
and then again to be warmed up.
And this happens with this fire here.
You see the burning reaction,
the combustion reaction is here is here -
let me choose another color -
the combustion reaction is carried out in the fuel,
this super hot air will rise upwards.
That's why it looks like the flames
move up, blaze up.
You will also see - and we will talk about it in thermal radiation -
that they also change their color as they move up.
But the whole idea of ​​the upward flame
and hot air -
if you put your hand here, it will be much hotter here,
than if you put your hand, let's say here,
although in theory it is closer to the flame,
than that here above, and that's because the hot air
rises up and makes room for the cold air,
or I have to say "the colder" air,
to go down and again to be warmed up,
and then he will rise again.
This convection, this idea,
that the hot air rises or the cold air falls,
this is another type of heat transfer.
The last species we observe,
when we look at the fire, is heat radiation.
And this is based on the idea,
if you have accelerating charged particles,
they will release electromagnetic radiation.
And you can say, "Wait, charged particles,
where are they speeding up here? "
Well, we have these molecules that are constantly accelerating,
until they hit each other.
One that will transfer kinetic energy from -
let's say this one is crushing into this one,
it will accelerate this in a different direction.
And even this one can go in another direction,
and acceleration is a change in speed,
so it can be in velocity
or in the direction of speed.
As they collide, you have all these accelerators
loaded particles - let me write this -
you have an acceleration of charged particles,
and then releases electromagnetic radiation.
I know what you think, "Wait a minute, Sal.
I understand that we have these molecules that are accelerating,
but where do these jobs come from with charged particles? "
Well, we must remember that these molecules
are made up of atoms, and the atoms are made up of charged particles,
are made of protons and electrons.
And while you accelerate these particles
and the more you speed them up,
the more radiation you will release.
You can say, "Okay, you say I watch this in the fire.
Where do I watch radiation? "
Well, the very fact that you can see the fire,
the light emanating from the fire,
this is electromagnetic radiation.
This is electromagnetic radiation from wavelengths,
which for your eye are visible light,
or which the eye receives for light.
Even the particles here above,
which are still quite hot,
they also emit electromagnetic radiation,
because they hit one another
and their electrons and protons
are accelerated in different directions.
They also release electromagnetic radiation,
but it has a slower wavelength,
than your eye can perceive as light.
If you have an infrared camera you will see that the flames are much higher.
You will see them here.
If you look at the flame closely
here below you will see exactly where the burning reaction happens,
that the flame looks blue.
And this is because the blue light is a light with higher energy
and this is because below the particles are accelerated more,
and then passes from blue to white to yellow,
to orange, to red,
and then disappears, at least for your eyes.
But everything that has some temperature,
releases electromagnetic radiation.
And you say to yourself, "That's good, I understand it,
but how is this a type of energy transfer? "
If you sit by some fire you will feel the heat.
In fact, even if the air between you and the flame is cold,
you still feel warm.
If this is a flame here
and, say, you have cold air -
let's say you're near campfire -
this air here is 30 degrees.
If you stay here, you will still feel the heat,
you will feel warmer.
This is because this electromagnetic radiation
is emitted from the air particles,
which we perceive as a flame,
and then it can excite the particles on your skin.
It will transfer energy to your skin
and you will feel warm.
I remember once, this is a strange story,
I was on the highway and had a flaming car.
We were driving in the leftmost band because the car was burning,
we were three stripes away from it
and it explodes.
I do not think there was anyone in it,
I hope there was not,
but I remember that just when it exploded,
we felt intense immediate heat
through the window of the car
and that was electromagnetic radiation.
It was thermal radiation released from these accelerated particles
in the air around this explosion,
which we perceive as an explosion or fire,
but it warmed up particles on my skin.